I don't know too much about wines apart
from if they're in right away if they're
red or white or if they're one of the
ten from drops of God I don't think it's
that but for always like I think it's
like pretty well known in Italy I think
the guy was like oh yeah if you want
like a walnut Italian wine like get
parole or so uh hey if anyone's watching
this episode or listening to this
episode probably more Italian let us
know if you know bro
I just don't think it like the [ __ ] is a
Barolo that's what they call Bordeaux
it's funny because how I got into wine
because how I got into wine initially
was literally drops of God because
before that I was like why does anyone
would drink wine I just want a cold beer
I don't want to like but after reading
you read Rob's good once and you're like
I love why why it's great I read drops
of God on a flight I think it was I
don't know it's from like America or
somewhere and I remembered reading drops
of God and you know one like the little
cart comes by yeah I'm a connoisseur of
fine tastes of course why even ask me
the question to ask I hope you were
drinking wine on the fly so she gets out
the little bottle of wine they crack
open pours it into this plastic cup for
me and it was like the most pathetic
drink out of hacks I was sitting there
like swirling this plastic cup that like
a ten-year-old would make a Jenga yeah
yeah because table wine we all know
table wine on flights is basically just
like grape juice with hand sanitizer in
it yeah it's disgusting
I mean cuz you you can't even taste like
things that aren't like super salty
right on home yes anyways yeah I feel
like wine is the worst thing I feel like
it's that point when you're watching
something that's super good like for
example when you're watching shokugeki
like this food looks amazing and you're
sitting there with your [ __ ] takeaway
combini